see you around ready you should have
gone for the head hey everybody its
charlie you guys probably saw the news
this morning
Thanos officially snapped every single
Marvel TV series on Netflix Punisher and
Jessica Jones were just cancelled and
the crazy thing is is that Jessica Jones
season 3 hasn't even aired yet they
completely shot the season and people
like well you know what'll probably
happen is is they'll wait to like a
month after they come out then Netflix
will cancel it
Netflix released an official statement
marvel with Jeff lobe released an
official statement and is also
speculated about what's gonna happen
with all these characters next so I'll
explain what they said because there is
a chance that some of them could come
back in some form we'll do a new round
of the Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Marvel Netflix moment on
the video Netflix is official statement
this morning just reads Marvel's The
Punisher will not return for a third
season on Netflix showrunner Stephen
Lightfoot the terrific crew the
exceptional cast including star Jon
Bernthal delivered an acclaimed and
compelling series for fans and we are
proud to showcase their work on Netflix
for years to come that last sentence is
critical to what happens next with all
these characters in these shows so they
say we're proud to showcase their work
on Netflix for years to come that means
that they're going to keep every episode
from all the series of all the Marvel
Netflix shows for years multiple years
not for forever but for multiple years
but where they probably give the rights
back to marble to do whatever they want
to with the episodes if they want to
repackage them and put them on a
different service like Hulu this is
Charlie Cox's official statement about
that save daredevil campaign they were
talking about a little while ago you
know I also vaguely hoping that the DD
will have another life at some point so
[Applause]
hi I found that sorry I'm so sorry I
found out the other day there's this
petition these guys are wearing this
thing save daredevil there's a thing you
can sign it sign it now sign it yeah hi
my name is Abigail I'm sorry I'm so
sorry
I'll be right with you I gave my
two-year-old daughter an email address
so that she could cite it she's sorry
is there an arc a story that you'd like
to see brought in as far as if there
were season four it's tricky because I I
it's tricky to answer this in fact I
have to be really careful here just
because I happen to know details of what
was planned and so in the off chance
that there would be at some point as you
know I wouldn't want to say too much but
what I can say which I think is vague
enough is that I would I'd be really
excited to see Benjamin Poindexter
really come into his own and really
really kind of embody bullseye and for
that to see that them face off so
remember that they're keeping all the
episodes this is their additional
statement about Jessica Jones because
they just cancelled that too
in addition reviewing our Marvel
programming we have decided that the
upcoming third season will also be the
final season for Marvel's Jessica Jones
were grateful to showrunner Melissa
Rosenberg star Krysten Ritter and the
entire cast and crew for three
incredible seasons of this
groundbreaking series which was
recognized by the Peabody Awards amongst
many others here's the sort of breakup
tag that they give to Marvel in general
because now all their shows are canceled
we are grateful to Marvel for five years
for our fruitful partnership and thank
the passionate fans who have followed
these series from the beginning that's
the classic breakup move where Netflix
is going to Disney and Marvel and saying
it's not you it's me that's why we're
breaking up but clearly it's because of
a lot of the stuff that Disney is doing
right now with the Disney streaming
service but I know a lot of you have
speculated like hey why don't they just
put all the shows on the Disney Plus
streaming service now and why don't they
put them on Hulu so the deal is
is that there is a two-year cooling-off
period for all the core defenders that's
daredevil Luke Cage iron fist and
Jessica Jones Punisher interestingly
enough is not part of that deal because
it's a spin-off of the daredevil TV show
but for all those four core defender
characters Variety reported about a
special contract clause between Marvel
and Netflix that there's a two-year
cooling-off period for the characters
that Marvel can't do anything with them
they can't put them in the movies they
can't put them in different TV shows for
two more years so remember that but then
separately just a couple days ago Jeff
Loeb and Marvel came out and did a
separate interview where they kind of
confirmed that they're planning on
bringing these characters and some of
these shows back this is what he said I
would not be surprised if any of those
things reimburse talking about the shows
and the characters it depends on
showrunner it depends on availability of
the cast all those things it's not like
we're a doctor's show where the show got
canceled because of bad ratings these
shows have a very different reason for
ending most of which I'm not at liberty
to talk about nor should anyone really
care about at the end of the day so you
know put your tinfoil hat on like I'm
not at liberty to talk about the real
reason why all these shows were canceled
but it doesn't take a genius or psychic
to figure out what's been going on
between Disney and Netflix in the
streaming wars Jeph Loeb also released
another statement just after Netflix
dropped the bomb like yeah no more
punisher no more jessica jones and he
said on behalf of everyone at marvel
television we couldn't be more proud or
grateful to our audience our network
partner may have decided that they no
longer want to continue telling these
tales of these great characters talking
about netflix not wanting to continue
but you know Marvel better than that as
Matthew Murdock's dad once said the
measure of a man is not how he gets
knocked to the mat is how he gets back
up to be continued and that's Jeff lobe
saying to be continued with air quotes
meaning that the characters will come
back eventually but here's the thing
like I said remember 2-year contractual
cooling-off period so no more daredevil
for the next two years no more Luke Cage
no more iron fist
no more Jessica Jones Punisher is
amazingly free to go wherever he wants
apparently unless there's some special
contract that we don't know about but
while a lot of people earlier speculated
the Disney was secretly gonna try and
just bring all those series over like I
said they're probably not going to
separate things because all the episodes
will stay with Ned
flix is just the characters that are now
free to go wherever marvel wants to put
them hulu did express an interest in
continuing some of the Marvel series but
like I said 2-year cooling-off period
and a lot of that depends on how much
money they're willing to spend on them
because they don't have Netflix level
money really good example of a Marvel
Hulu show is Runaways it's aimed more at
younger kids and they spend way less
money on it it's like something that you
would find on ABC Family like imagine
that level of show in order to produce
daredevil and Punisher and some of the
bigger Marvel Netflix shows especially
Luke Cage with that giant music budget
you have to spend crazy money and even
though Disney now owns most of Hulu and
they have very deep pockets unless
they're willing to take a bath to
continue these series what I would
rather see them do is is if they're
gonna continue them in the TV shows is
they just combine them and just do a
defenders team-up show instead of doing
like four or five different TV shows
it's cheaper for them and you get more
bang for your buck because you get more
heroes in a single show the very first
moment that they announce Luke Cage and
iron fist were getting TV shows we said
why don't they just team them up and do
Heroes for Hire from the start why are
they doing separate TV shows just put
them together the other option is that
some of the characters go into the
movies like you've been wondering will
Punisher ever go to the MCU
well daredevil huge comic-book character
ever go to the MCU that is totally
possible now after that two-year
cooling-off period is done but what'll
probably happen is is we won't find out
where they're going next for a long time
like they'll just talk about it like
we'll be a Comic Con this summer we'll
get the whole phase four movie schedule
Kevin Feige will be like look at all the
x-men projects that we're making look at
the really awesome Fantastic Four movie
that we're gonna be making then there's
all the Avengers spin-off TV shows that
they're making for the Disney Plus
streaming service don't forget that that
has nothing to do with Geoff lobe or
Marvel TV that's Kevin Feige and all the
movie people producing those so like the
one with Tom Hiddleston the Loki TV show
that they just announced the Scarlet
Witch and vision show the Winter Soldier
show all separate from Marvel TV will
get trailers for all that stuff probably
a Comic Con and when we do I'll just
remind people about where it's all
coming from and how it's all connected
because technically Marvel everything is
supposed to be connected but really some
things are more
connected than others so for now two
years all those Marvel Netflix people
are riding the bench what's gonna happen
next is is you're gonna hear every news
outlet and every blogger every youtuber
talking about where these series are
headed next but it's probably gonna be a
long time before Marvel officially tells
us what they're gonna do with the
characters and with the future of these
TV shows I think you'll probably be okay
if I don't make videos for Jessica Jones
season 3 because they've already
cancelled it that'll air later this year
so if you are a big fan of that series
you'll still be able to watch all those
episodes but when Jeff lope says
bringing these things back just depends
on actor availability showrunner
availability that doesn't mean right now
that means in two years when the
cooling-off period is done post all your
reactions in the comments below which
series are you most bummed about getting
cancelled there's a whole bunch of
Captain Marvel Avengers endgame in
Shazam trailer stuff dropping this week
so I'll do videos for all that stuff is
at post while you wait for everything
click here for my brand new spider-man
far from home video and click here for
my brand new Avengers endgame trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight
you